[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is flm and I'll be your
host today so without further Ado let's
dive into today's episode and embark on
a great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired today's
topic will be about bullying in school
where we will be discussing about the
causes
consequences and strategies to combat
bullying in educational
institution bullying in school is a
deeply ingrained problem that affect
student of all ages and its consequences
are far reaching
let's break down
into three essential components causes
consequences and strategies to combat
bullying in our educational
institution first let's talk about the
causes why does bullying happen in
school it's a complex issues with no
single answer but some common factors
include power and balance peer pressure
and intolerance it's important important
to note that there is no single cause of
bullying and it often results from a
combination of these and other factors
efforts to prevent and address bullying
in school involve a combination of
educal initiative promoting empathy
involving parents and the community and
establishing clear policies and
consequences for bullying Behavior
creating a safe and inclusive School
environment m is crucial in addressing
this issue some of the causes of
bullying is power imbalance peer
pressure insecurity and low self-esteem
lack of empathy home environment social
media and technology and a lot of other
causes power imbalance bullying often
involves a power imbalance where one
person or a group exerted control or
dominis over another this power Dominic
can be based on physical strength social
status or other factors peer pressure
some students May bully other to fit in
with a particular social group or to
avoid becoming a Target themselves peer
pressure can be a significant motivator
for bullying Behavior insecurity and low
self-esteem bullies may have their own
insecurities and low self-esteem by
targeting others they may feel a
temporary boost in their own
self-esteem lack of empathy some
individuals lack empathy and have
difficulty understanding or caring about
the feelings of others this can lead to
aggressive and hurtful
Behavior home environment how life and
family Dynamics can play a role in
bullying Behavior children who witness
or experience violence aggression or
bullying at home may be more likely to
replicate these behaviors at school
social media and Technology with the
rise of digital communication cyber
bullying has become a significant issue
online anonymity can embolden
individuals to engage in bullying
Behavior next let's consider the
consequences bullying impact can be
severe for victims it can result in
physical and emotional distress from
anxiety and depression to physical
injuries the academic performance of
these students can suffer
significantly as for the bullies they
often face disciplinary consequences and
may grapple with their own mental health
issues long term effs can include the
higher risk of mental health problems
and then increased likelihood of
engaging in criminal Behavior I will be
stopping to talk about some consequences
is that it's that are happening in life
right now emotional and physiological
effects victims who those who are
bullying May Express a range of negative
emotions including anxiety depression LW
of self-esteem and a SC of isolation but
bullies bullies themselves can
experience emotional and pH
psychological issues such as increased
aggression antisocial behavior and an
incre increased risk of mental health
problem academic consequences bullying
can have a significant impact on a
student's academic performance victims
May struggle to concentrate on their
studies due to emotional distress
leading to a decline in grades physical
health
effects physical health effects at
victims chronic stress from bullying can
lead to physical health problems
including headaches stomach aches and
sleep
disturbance but at bullies its engaging
in bullying Behavior can result in
physical harm to others and an increased
risk of injuries to
themselves social isolation bullying can
lead to social isolation as victims may
become withdrawn and they have
difficulty forming friendship they may
fear social situations and avoid School
Al together I'm stoping at Cy bullying
in the digital age sapon bulling can
lead to online harassment reputation
damage and potential exposure on to
inappropriate content further impacting
a student's mental health and emotional
health suicidal thoughts and actions
some victims of bullying especially in
cases of severe abuse may experience a
suicidal thoughts or even attempt self
harm or suicide it's important to
recognize that addressing bullies is not
only about addressing the immediate harm
but also about preventing the long-terms
consequences schools and communities
need to take proactive
measurements to prevent and respond to
bullying create safe and inclusive
environments and provide support for
both victims and perers to change their
behavior early
interation and education are critical in
combin in combination and the negative
consequences of bullying in
school so we will have the questions
what can we do to combat bullying in our
educational
institution the strategies are
multiun School must prioritize creating
a safe and inclusive environment where
students feel valued and respected this
involves promoting empathy tolerance and
divers diversity educational institution
should establish anti-bullying policies
with clear reporting mechanism and
consequences for bullying Behavior
teacher and staff need training to
recognize and address bullying and
students should receive education about
its effect and how to support one
another but does it need the N there no
parents and The Wider Community also
have a role to play parent can support
their children in
developing empathy and conflict
resolution skills while also keeping an
eye out for signs that their children
might be involved in
bullying the community can contribute by
organizing anti-bullying campaigns
offering resources for parents and
providing counseling service for both
victims and Bullies a unite front from
school to parents and the community is
essential to tackle this issue before we
wrap up remember that bullying is
preventable by fostering safe and
inclusive School environments and
teaching empathy promoting diversity and
taking a strong STS against bullying we
can Ensure that our educational
institutions are place to growth respect
and well-being for all the
students thank you so much for joining
us on this episode of high school
memories it's been an incredible journey
and we're so glad you came along for the
ride until next time take
[Music]
care
a